[Music]
thank you to brilliant for supporting
PBS Digital Studios did you hear the one
about the IRS agent who filed tax
returns in other people's names to
collect hundreds of thousands of dollars
in stolen tax refunds it's scary one or
what about the Australian woman whose
personal information was used to make a
fake passport which ended up implicating
her in an international assassination
ring oh that would be so freaky oh and
then there's the one with the tenant who
with just a couple of pieces of stolen
mail opened dozens of credit cards and
her landlords name I can't hear anything
they say on a quiet night you can still
hear him arguing with a customer service
representative
it's not funny Phillip identity theft
isn't just a scary story it can happen
to anyone I mean with the Equifax and
Facebook hacks we can be next Shh what's
that sound oh stop it
no really it came from over there
[Music]
if you haven't already fallen prey to
some kind of financial fraud odds are
pretty good that you will in your
lifetime a recent survey by the Bureau
of Justice Statistics found seventeen
point six million Americans more seven
percent of people over 16 will be a
victim of identity theft each year the
vast majority of these incidents are
unauthorized uses of credit cards or
bank accounts but these criminals will
also use stolen info to pay for medical
treatments intercept tax refunds cash
and airline miles and set up utilities
like water and electricity while the
frequency of identity theft is
alarmingly high the good news is that
the monetary damage for most people is
usually small according to a study
conducted by the Federal Trade
Commission only 14% of identity theft
victims were not reimbursed for their
loss and only 7% suffered a loss of $100
or more the bigger risk is the amount of
time and effort victims often have to
spend to untangle the real identity from
the fake one a stolen credit card can
usually be cleared up in a few hours but
if a thief opens new accounts in your
name it can haunt you for years some
victims don't even find out they've been
compromised until they start getting
letters from collection agencies or go
into a bank to open an account and find
out they have already got one and
clearing your name can be a rabbit hole
of bureaucracy lenders and credit
agencies tend to demand a lot of proof
when you're trying to get out of paying
a debt like passports driver's licenses
social security cards birth certificates
police reports signed affidavits yeah if
only they had those high standards when
the fraudsters were racking up the debt
in the first place and if your info was
used to pay for hospital fees or
medications your medical record might be
mixed up with your identity thieves so
not only could it be hard to get a
mortgage in the future you might not be
able to get health insurance thankfully
situations this extreme are pretty rare
but the risk isn't going away if you've
been watching the news in the past year
you might have heard there's a whole lot
of hacking going on sony target Equifax
Facebook so many people have been
compromised it's not
really a matter of if it's a matter of
when and that when can be way in the
future things like your name birthday
and social security number are ever
graded hackers can sit on that info for
decades before deciding to use it so
what can you do
thankfully the vast majority of banks
and credit cards offer zero liability
protection to account holders meaning
you will be completely refunded if
you're victimized by fraud that's great
for accounts you already have but what
about new lines of credit someone could
open in your name the three major credit
bureaus Equifax TransUnion and Experian
are required by law to provide you with
a free credit report once a year and
you'll be able to see pretty quickly if
there are accounts on there you don't
recognize you've probably also seen ads
for companies that will monitor your
credit activity more closely for a
monthly fee some even search the dark
web to see if your information is being
bought or sold on the Internet's black
markets but most of these precautions
are reactive their purpose is to alert
you quickly once you've become a target
the only proactive thing you can do to
protect yourself is freeze your credit
don't worry it doesn't mean you have to
turn in your charge cards freezing your
credit means no one will be able to open
new lines of credit in your name even
you so if you don't plan on applying for
any new loans in the near future it
might be a good idea surprisingly even
though two-thirds of respondents to a
recent poll said they were worried their
identity had been compromised in last
year's Equifax breach only 19% reported
taking any kind of precautionary steps
not even finding out whether they were
one of the victims maybe they were
counting on technology to protect them
maybe they figure their safety in
numbers or maybe they're just too busy
to worry about a problem until it's on
their doorstep one thing is certain
identity thieves have a perfect victim
in mind when they're on the hunt this
person doesn't keep a very close eye on
their account balances they don't ever
check their credit report or communicate
regularly with their bank this is a
person who can be victimized for years
before even knowing it so while you can
never protect yourself a hundred percent
from identity thieves there's no reason
you should make it easy
for them and that's our two cents it's
our mission at two cents to inspire you
to be a lifelong learner thinker and
problem solver
that's why PBS Digital Studios is proud
to be supported by brilliant brilliant
is an online platform designed to help
you with hands-on practice for subjects
like math science and technology one of
the best ways to learn these skills is
by doing not just observing and with
brilliant you'll be actively learning as
you solve puzzles and work your way
through guide to tutorials you can learn
more at brilliant org slash two cents
[Music]